for us modern humans with our easy
access to the local supermarket it's
easy to forget that throughout human
history and even today the amount of
humans or the human population has been
limited by our ability to get calories
or get human consumable food from the
land so i want to do in this video is
give us a little bit of a framework for
thinking about how humans have been
getting calories from the land and what
that how that's placed an upper limit on
the number of humans that can live in
any given area or the the population
density of humans so right over here you
have some gentlemen looking for food
they are hunter gatherers i'll say h g
for short and the h part the hunter part
they might actually find some animals i
think these guys right over here are
trying to trap some rabbits and the
gathering part they're just literally
looking for food maybe they find fruit
of some sort or some nuts or some or
some uh maybe some roots that are that
are edible by humans so literally they
just walk around either try to kill
things or find things that they can
consume so i'll call this i'll call this
right over here stage one actually let
me write over here so this is hunter
gathers and this is what most humans
have done through most of human history
and just to give us a little bit of a
framework for maybe how much they could
get from the land and i looked at some
of the
our best sense of studying
hunter-gatherer populations in in land
like this maybe they can get about 200
calories 200 200 and i'll make this
whole column right over here this whole
column right over here is the amount
that they could get in terms of calories
per square kilometer
per
calories per square kilometer per day
now it's obviously going to be hugely
dependent on the number of animals that
are there
the type of land that's there if they're
next to a stream where maybe fish are
just jumping out of the stream this
number would be much higher if they were
in some type of a desert this number
would be much lower but this is actually
fairly in line with some of the studies
of hunter-gatherer cultures now if this
is the number of calories that they can
get from each square kilometer per day
how many humans can live in a square
kilometer per day or what is the density
of humans well to figure that out we
have to know on average how many
calories does a human need to survive
and for the sake of this video i'm going
to make the assumption that a human
being needs two thousand
two thousand calories two thousand
calories per day to survive in a
non-malnourished state and obviously
it's usually dependent on how active
this person is or how large they are and
one other note this whole video i'm
going to be using calories with a
capital c and the calories are with the
capital c are the calories that people
are used to referring to when you go to
the gym and you run on the treadmill it
says how many calories you've burned or
you look at the back of your candy bar
and it says 200 calories these are the
calories i'm talking about they are a
slightly different notion than the
calories that you encounter in chemistry
class those calories are calorie
with a lowercase c
and just so that you can be optimally
confused it turns out that one calorie
one calorie with an upper kc is equal to
one thousand one thousand calories with
a lower kc
1000 calories and the lowercase c
calories is the amount of energy needed
to heat one gram of water one degrees
celsius and so this is what you see in
your chemistry class but this is not
what we're going to be talking about in
this video we're talking about the
capital c the calories you talk that
that dietitians are always talking about
so with this assumption that the average
human eats 2 000 calories a day to not
get malnourished and obviously men would
need more women would need less children
would need
children would need even less but with
this assumption what is the density of
humans that could be supported by this
culture right over here
well 200 calories is one tenth of the
average daily human requirement if you
believe this assumption so the
population density
so the density in let me write it humans
humans per square kilometer you can only
support one tenth of a human with this
with this calorie output so you can only
support one tenth of a human per square
kilometer so one human would actually
need 10 square kilometers of hunter
gathering of to hunt from and gather
from in order to support just themselves
they would need maybe 30 or 40 square
kilometers to support an entire family
so they could wander around and kill the
animals and find whatever they need to
find on that land now let's go to kind
of you can view it as maybe the next
stage although it's not always the case
that herding is going to be more
productive than hunter-gatherers
especially in the case where the fish
are jumping out of the water
but let's go to this scenario right over
here so this is we can call this a
pastoral lifestyle
so this is
two i'll call it pastoral
and over here is the realization that
look you have all of this all of this
vegetation that maybe humans can't
consume but there are other animals that
can consume this vegetation and they can
turn those calories into calories that
can consume that can be consumed by a
human and namely them the calories are
themselves so this gentleman right over
here after he gets these these these
sheep to be nice and fat he can either
eat the sheep or he can drink their milk
so one way to think about is these these
this these this cattle or these sheep
right over here by herding them and
letting them eat the grass he's turning
non-human consum
non-human consumable calories into human
consumable calories and so for the sake
of our thought experiment let's say we
get a 10 times increase in the human
consumable calories per square kilometer
so now instead of 200 we're up to 2 000
and so instead of one human per square
kilometer we have enough calories per
square kilometer per day to support one
human so instead of sorry instead of 0.1
we can now support one human so in that
10 square kilometers we can now support
10 people and 100 square kilometers we
could now support a hundred people
now the next stage and i'm skipping a
bunch of stages so because you have
things like
subsistence agriculture and and various
forms that they're not going to be
equally productive and it depends what
the land is like and it depends what the
tools are at at your disposal but the
next stage that i'll just kind of jump
to
we can call traditional agriculture so
this right over here let's call that
traditional agriculture and that's this
one over here as well so both of these
i'm going to call traditional
agriculture and for the for the purposes
of this video the difference between
traditional agriculture and modern
agriculture in traditional agriculture
you didn't have mechanization so you
didn't you had or very primitive
mechanization you definitely did not
have fossil fuel based engines you
didn't have modern pesticides you did
not have modern genetically engineered
crops but you did have some of the basic
science of breeding crops and irrigating
and using animals as tools so in this
stage right over here and once again it
completely depends on where you are on
the planet how fertile the land is how
good your tools are what crops you're
actually producing let's assume that we
got a hundred fold increase in
productivity and looking at some of the
historical records it looks like
depending on once again where you are
that's not out of the realm of
possibility
so you have a hundred fold increase so
instead of two thousand calories per
square kilometer per day you can get two
hundred thousand two hundred thousand
calories per square kilometer per day
and now you could support 100 humans per
square kilometer if you wanted to so you
might not have a hundred humans one not
all the land might you have to be able
to farm from or they you just that's you
there are other limits on the population
for for whatever they might be but the
important thing to think about this
upper bound in this traditional if you
are able to get this type of
productivity from your land and you're
able to in theory support a hundred
people per square kilometer that means
if all of a sudden you have 200 people
living there maybe everyone's migrated
to this land because it seems especially
fertile or all the really smart farmers
live there then all of a sudden not
everyone's going to be able to get 2 000
calories a day some people might not get
malnourished other people might actually
starve there there's this upper bound on
the actual number of people that can be
there based on how productive the land
actually is and now let's move over to
modern agriculture and we've already
talked a little bit about what exactly
is
modern agriculture you have you have
machines like this combine over here
that does a lot of the human labor one
human can can
and
and i'll talk about the different
dimensions because there's actually two
dimensions here how much how much
calories can you get from the land and
how much energy can one human how much
labor can one human do
input into the land using tools at their
disposal so in this case cattle need
these ox pulling this plow or in this
case this combine that's fueled by
fossil fuels
but in modern agriculture because of all
of the things you have these amazing
tools you have genetically engineered
crops you have modern pesticides and not
everyone is a fan of all of these things
but they have hugely increased our
productivity so you have modern
agriculture and let's say that you get
another factor of 10 from traditional
agriculture so now you can get two
million
calories per square kilometer per day or
you can support one thousand you can
support one thousand humans one thousand
humans per square kilometers and once
again this right over here this right
over here is an upper bound and just to
give a sense and i picked these numbers
just so that the numbers would be clean
i looked at some historical records
these aren't completely out of line with
what it looks like humans have been able
to do in the past but to give you a
sense of what human population densities
look like right now and why this upper
bound seems to be right about correct in
a place like the united states so in the
united states the population density is
30 people per square kilometer so this
is 30 humans per square kilometer in a
more dense country or significantly more
dense country like india the population
density is 300 humans per square
kilometer and in the most population
dense country in the world which is
where i come from or actually i was born
in new orleans but where my where some
of my ancestors came from
which is bangladesh
so there's a lot of people like me i
guess
in bangladesh you have a population
density of 900
humans
per square kilometer and to some degree
this is a testament to the fertility of
the land and whatever else but this is
pretty near the limits depending on
agricultural productivity and whatnot in
the land of modern
technology so it really makes you think
if you don't get population under
control you might end up with some of
these kind of hitting the wall type of
scenarios and so the last thing i want
you to think about and this is what i
refer to a little bit more is just think
about those two dimensions because
sometimes they get a little bit muddled
one is the kind of the productivity of
land
productivity
of land and then the other is the
productivity of labor
productivity of
labor so right over here in a
hunter-gatherer they're not getting
money calories from their land so
they're right over there and the humans
have to do all the labor they're not
they don't have animals helping them in
any way they definitely don't have
robots or any type of engines helping
them in any way and so there's so they
have to spend a lot of human time and a
lot of human labor doing the work
getting that productivity from the land
but as we progress so as we progress
with things that aid humans so for
example
if you all of a sudden you have cattle
helping you or you have other tools that
that help you you get more human
productivity so less and less of human
labor has to be used to get that
productivity of the land so maybe other
humans can go do other things like paint
pictures or become blacksmiths or
whatever and in this direction you get
higher productivity per unit of land and
so that comes from moving from hunter
gatherer to a pastoral lifestyle to
traditional farming with irrigation to
modern farming and so in this on this
graph right over here tech kind of tools
for the individuals move us up getting
more productivity the land moves to the
right modern agriculture gets us right
over here so we're getting many we're
getting much much more calories per unit
land and we're getting much much more
calories per unit labor so you need much
fewer
a much smaller percentage of the human
population actually involved in the
farming anyway i'll let you go there
hopefully that gives you at least an
understanding of you know the food isn't
just it doesn't just come from nowhere
and it really is a rate limiting factor
on humanity's population